The Gomu Gomu no mi is not what you think
it is.
There is a reason, why Shanks went out of
his way to steal the fruit and a reason why
it makes Luffy so special.
And it's time to find out what it is.
Because maybe shanks used the fruit to determine
the man who can bring the dawn.
And maybe, just maybe, it's not actually the
Gomu Gomu no mi after all, but a mythical
devil fruit.
Hi my name is Manu, and as you can tell, I
have been on a bit of a streak with videos
on Luffy lately.
Even though Zoro is my favorite Character,
Luffy is not far behind for me.
And I have made several videos already about
why I think he's the best-written shounen
protagonist out there.
But recent developments in One Piece have
had me obsessed about Luffy's true nature
and powers and how Oda is clearly teasing
us with something about Luffy that he's deliberately
holding back right now.
For the longest time, it seemed to me like
Luffy eating the Gomu Gomu no mi was merely
a coincidence.
He was hanging out with Shanks and his men,
who had brought the fruit with them and while
they were looking away Luffy took it as a
nice little snack in between.
Good for you luffy, eating healthy.
Later Shanks apparently on a whim saw something
special in Luffy, so he motivated him to become
a pirate and gave him his hat as inspiration.
And it was only thanks to Luffy's creativity
that the Gomu Gomu no mi seemed more than
average at best to me as a power.
AH.
Remember when one piece seemed that simple.
Now everything has seemed to have changed
and to me this first chapter of One Piece
seems filled to the brim with foreshadowing
and setup for the endgame of the story.
But looking at all I have to share with you
in this video, it's so exciting, I can't really
complain.
With Oden's flashback, we have gotten a lot
of new insights into the workings of Roger
and his journey to Laugh Tale.
Shanks has turned out to be one of the most
influential characters in the story, with
ties to Roger, the other Yonko and the Gorosei
alike.
Instead of a simple pirate that likes to party
most of the time, he is the man pulling the
strings on political developments and the
future of the world---and still likes to party
most of the time.
As you might know, I'm convinced that Shanks
did not simply show up in Fusha Village, because
he was aimlessly sailing around the east blue.
Shanks was extremely close to Roger and even
inherited his precious straw hat.
We now know that Roger and his men came to
Laugh Tale to early and that the pirate king
was waiting for the one who could bring
the dawn.
That's why he created the new pirate era to
inspire as many people as possible to find
it.
He then ordered his men, to find the right
person and guide him towards the last island,
to find the one piece.
That is why Rayleigh was waiting at the entrance
to the new world, as the only one able to
coat ships, keeping a close eye on everyone
who came though and immediately recognising
Luffy for who he was.
Why crocus was guarding the entrance to the
Grandline at reverse mountain, where he surely
recognised Luffy the same way and made sure
he found his way.
I bet he didn't give out a free log pose to
everyone and explained how to use it.
And finally, Shanks was tasked with finding
the right member of the D. Family to inherit
Rogers Will.
I would bet my favorite coffee mug, that Shanks
came to Fusha village to find Ace, not Luffy,
the son of his former captain, that was determined
on having a son of his own to succeed him.
And it's the same reason, he left right away,
never to be seen in the east blue again, right
after entrusting Luffy with Roger's hat and
sacrificing his arm to ensure he would become
the one who can bring the dawn.
Whether he knew how powerful luffy would become
and who his parents were, I don't know.
However, I will make videos on both, Luffy's
possible powers after Wano and a who his mother
might be soon, so if you want to see those
and are a true mad-lad, make sure to subscribe.
And now, with recent chapters, speculation
around devil fruits and more specifically
Luffy's fruit has gotten a lot of fresh wind.
From here on out Spoiler warning if you are
not caught up with the story yet.
I was completely shocked, when we found out
form Who's Who that Shanks did not simply
stumble across this specific devil fruit,
but went out of his way to steal if from the
world government itself, while it was protected
by CP9.
That and the reveal of Sun God Nika, which
will actually be important later on.
And so it now begs the question, whether Shanks
didn't just chose Luffy as the next possible
pirate king, because he reminded him of Roger,
but because Luffy snacked on the most important
fruit in the whole story.
And so I now want to discuss with you all
the exciting possibilities for what could
possibly make a the rubber devil fruit so
special.
But before we eat desert, first some veggies.
Let's assume that the fruit wasn't special
after all?
Why did Shanks go out of his way and risk
war with the government to steal it, if it
wasn't super important to him?
One possibility could be that shanks actually
made a bit of a woopie when stealing the fruit.
Since he seems to have been the only one aware
of how dangerous blackbeard truly is, he might
well be aware of his connection to Rocks D.
Xebec or wherever Teach got the idea for the
Yami Yami no mi from.
Maybe the government mistook the gomu gomu
no mi for its much more powerful counterpart
and information about it leaked through to
Shanks.
Only after stealing the fruit did he realize
that he had not gotten his hands on the Yami
Yami no mi after all.
Another possibility is that one of the celestial
dragons had purchased Luffy's fruit for a
lot of money and wanted to use it for one
of their slaves, which is why CP9 was instructed
with its transport.
But I personally think, that Oda wouldn't
have gone out of his way to bring Shanks stealing
the fruit from the government up like this,
if it weren't important in some way or form.
As I discussed in my character analysis of
shanks, he is someone that usually tries to
avoid conflict and fighting, trying to be
the mediator with pirates and the gorosei
alike.
So, I feel there must be something very special
about the Gomu Gomu no mi, for him to actually
attack a government ship.
I think that the fruit is special in some
way and Shanks used it to find the next Joy
boy.
So, once Luffy had eaten it, there was no
alternative for him, but to bet everything
on Luffy.
So what could be so special about it?
I think there are three different options
here.
Number 1: It's not about the fruit itself,
but who wielded it before luffy.
Number 2: The fruit actually has a hidden
power, that makes it way more powerful and
dangerous than it appears.
Or number 3: The name of Luffy's devil fruit
is actually not the Gomu Gomu no mi at all,
but actually a legendary Zoan fruit.
Let's start with one.
This is based on a theory of mine about the
true nature of devil fruits that I've shared
before.
If you want to hear my full line of reasoning
and proof for this, I suggest you check out
that video, but here's what you need to know:
It seems like devil fruits posses a will of
their own.
Some sort of spirit, that is related to the
devil that gives its user their power.
This seems likely as we have seen inanimate
objects gain consciousness by eating a devil
fruit.
And we do know that the soul is a real thing
in One Piece from Brook's and Big Mom's abilities.
Another major theme in one piece is that of
inherited will.
I suspect that when someone eats a devil fruit,
they merge with their own soul and once the
user dies, a part of them lives on in the
devil fruit.
Once someone else consumes this fruit, they
seems to take on some traits of the previous
user.
We have seen this with Sabo, after eating
ace's fruit.
Saying the same things and using the same
abilities, even though sabo never saw ace
use the fruit.
[] Or with Big Mom, who behaves a lot like
mother caramel after consuming her---fruit.
The point Im trying to make, is that the Gomu
fruit might have belonged to someone very
important, someone who's will Luffy now has
inherited.
The prime two candidates here are Roger and
Joy Boy.
Roger possibly finding the fruit on laugh
tale, eating it and then passing away soon
after.
And indeed, only shortly after eating the
fruit, Luffy starts saying the same things
as Roger, something he keeps doing throughout
the story.
So maybe, Luffy inherited Rogers or Joy boys
will through the GOmu GOmu no mi and that's
why it was so important to shanks.
One thing that I think is important to address
here: If the fruit is that important, why
didn't shanks eat it himself?
He stated in the story that neither he nor
any of his crew would eat a devil fruit, since
they all need to be ablate swim.
I'm not sure why, but I feel like this will
be important at some point.
Okay, Two.
The Fruit has a hidden power, that we don't
yet know about.
A possibility here is that the Gomu Gomu no
mi might be the perfect counter to another
fruit.
We have already seen this happen with Enel,
who also wielded an incredibly powerful fruit.
Another good fit could be the gura gura no
mi, the strongest paramecia fruit.
In theory, Luffy's awakening might be the
perfect counter to Blackbeards abilities.
Rubber doesn't break.
And luffy as sun god Nika is the natural enemy
of Blackbeard's darkness.
A problem with this idea is that the gura
gura no mi was still in possession of Whitebeard
12 years ago.
So only if shanks knew that Blackbeard was
after the fruit would that make sense.
But who knows, maybe the previous user was
Rocks and Shanks suspected Blackbeard would
try to gain it for himself.
But maybe the power is not really related
to another fruit, but what it can do on its
own.
Maybe the Gomu GOmu no mi in some way or form
is the key to changing the world.
Some ability you will need on laugh tale to
unlock the one piece.
One idea of how this might become relevant
is Luff's ability to enlarge his body parts
into that of giants.
And as you know there is a lot of interest
in giants in one piece.
Everyone wants them.
The government, Big Mom even Kaido with the
numbers.
Giants appear a lot in past events.
We have a D. Giant with Saul, we have the
giant frozen straw hat in marijoe and we even
have seen a giant with Luffy's personality,
with Oars.
So it's quite possible that Luffy's fruit
might allow him to turn into a giant, which
might be the key to bringing the dawn.
The third option is probably my favorite one,
though I have to say upfront even for my standards,
it's a bit of a stretch.
Since we're talking about Luffy, that might
be okay.
And its an incredibly fun one.
This theory is by a reddit user called The
biggest wheel, maybe a wheel of Time reference,
who proposes that the fruit the Gorosei are
discussing in chapter 1037 is actually Luffy's
and that the Gomu GOmu no mi is just a name
that the government came up with to erase
its true nature from history.
The base of this theory is Luff's resemblence
with the Wisdom King Myouou [] as well as
the introduction of sun god Nika.
Both of these gods can be linked to luffy.
The idea then, is that Luffy actually ate
the mythical Zoan devil fruit of the wisdom
king.
Basically Luffy's rubber abilities stay the
same, however they're just part of his creature,
like the healing ability for Marco's phoenix.
Going off the latest chapter, that this fruit
hasn't awakened in centuries, the author then
argues, that the original owner of this fruit
might have been the very person, that was
seen as god Nika, in other words, Joy Boy
himself.
So maybe Luffy is just awakening this very
unique devil fruit right now?
The design of gear fourth is so fundamentally
different from anything we have seen so far
from luffy.
Not only does he literally resemble a wisdom
king, but he has 3 forms of gear 4th, just
like Zoan fruits have multiple forms, as we
can see with chopper.
The key to this is really, another unexplained
power that luffy has.
Red hawk has been pretty much a mystery ever
since luffy was able to use it.
And now we actively see him using red roc,
the only attack Kaido has bothered dodging
so far.
Wisdom kings are usually depicted with firey
hair, just as sun god Nika seems to be.
And Oda once made this street fighter Ken
version of Luffy, but Ken clearly doesn't
have fire hair.
The design of the wisdom king pops up A lot
throughout one piece.
We have Enel, who pretends to be a god, this
figure during the fire festival and of course
king, who has fire powers as well.
Nika and the wisdom king.
Shandora and Wano, two nations closely connected
through their history and their ties to the
ancient kingdom.
So the craziest, but most existing option
here, is that Shanks stole the GOmu GOmu no
mi, because in reality it is one of the strongest
devil fruits out there and belonged to Joy
Boy himself.
But even if we assume that the GOmu GOmu no
mi is just the rubber fruit, there are still
a lot of great possibilities for luffy's awakening.
And there is a lot more to learn about devil
fruits.
So check out either of these two video here
to learn More.